Які існують професії, в чому їхні відмінності, як знайти собі фах до душі?
Говорити про це з дитиною не просто потрібно, а необхідно
Найкраще такі розмови починати з 12 років
У цьому віці в дитини вже є розуміння, що їй подобається, а що – ні
є досвід, є хобі
Почніть розмову про майбутній фах першими
Поцікавтеся, що подобається дитині,
якою роботою вона хотіла б займатися
Часто уявлення дитини про професію формується
з досвіду її родини та впливу Інтернету
Хоча сучасний світ пропонує сотні напрямів
Краще розібратися з цим різноманіттям допоможе практика
Сходіть на день відкритих дверей у заклад професійної освіти
Відвідайте ярмарок професій або майстер-клас
Нехай юна особистість спробує себе у ролі кухаря чи перукаря
Розпитає кравця або будівельника про їхню роботу
Поєднання власного інтересу з досвідом допоможе визначитися
з фахом та залишитися задоволеними
Не бійтеся довіряти власній дитини
Адже реалізація власних талантів зробить її дуже щасливою